die ebola epidemie in afrika ist völlig
außer kontrolle
das ist nicht die erfindung eines
boulevard blatt sondern der
einsatzleiter von ärzte ohne grenzen hat
jetzt alarm geschlagen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation will
einen sondergipfel noch diese woche in
ghana einberufen
solche bilder sind inzwischen nicht mehr
außergewöhnlich in guinea finder marica
nano ist schwach sie hat nasenbluten und
starke magenschmerzen die 30 meter zum
krankenwagen kann sie kaum noch laufen
in behandlungszentrum von ärzte ohne
grenzen wird ebola diagnostiziert die
aktuelle epidemie hat sich zum
schlimmsten ausbruch von ebola seit der
entdeckung des virus in den 70er jahren
entwickelt noch nie gab es so viele
infizierte und tote während die
etablierten presse schnell wieder das
interesse an der solche verloren hatte
konnte die entwicklung auf klicks und de
regelmäßig verfolgt werden
die schlimmste befürchtung dass ein
reisender die tödliche
infektionskrankheit nach kanada
eingeschleppt hatte bestätigte sich ende
märz gott sei dank nicht da
interessierte die traditionellen medien
schon bald nicht mehr welche
katastrophale entwicklung der ausbruch
in westafrika nahm seit ende märz hat
sich die anzahl der infizierten
versechsfacht und die zahl der toten ist
ebenfalls deutlich gestiegen von 60 auf
340 die epidemie konnte bisher nicht
eingedämmt werden
im gegenteil ärzte ohne grenzen spricht
von einer neuen welle sogar in städten
wie cognac rego monrovia trat der virus
erstmals seit seiner entdeckung auf zwei
tage nach der diagnose ist finger marie
gestorben
der ebola virus hat ihre blutgefäße
zerstört sie ist innerlich verblutet
zunächst wird sie nicht in einen
luftdichten leichensack gepackt was
nötig ist um die verbreitung der seuche
zu verhindern
die angehörigen sollen die leiche sehen
was nämlich den ausbruch nahezu
unbeherrschbar macht ist die bevölkerung
in den betroffenen ländern
sie misstraut den ersten und verdächtigt
sie den virus eingeschleppt zu haben und
den opfern in den quarantäne-station
organe zu entnehmen und die leichen
auszutauschen
im april mündete das misstrauen in einen
angriff auf eine station von ärzte ohne
grenzen
die mediziner mussten daraufhin das
behandlungszentrum verlassen
die ausbreitung der seuche wird zudem
durch die traditionen begünstigt der
virus wird lediglich durch direkten
kontakt übertragen
tote werden in der region allerdings
gewaschen und dabei von zahlreichen
trauernden berührt
die übertragung des virus wird dadurch
extrem begünstigt entwarnung gibt es
aber wohl für das restliche ausland die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who und die
europäische solchen börde ii cdc haben
die gefahr einer ausbreitung in den rest
der welt neu bewertet sie kommen zu dem
schluss dass sie solche nicht auf das
außer afrikanische ausland übergreifen
kann es wird keine empfehlung gegeben
nicht in die betroffenen länder zu
fliegen
reisenden wird lediglich empfohlen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu treffen wie
der vermeidung von direktem kontakt dem
waschen von früchten keinem verzehr von
wildfleisch wie zum beispiel
affenfleisch safer sex und so weiter
sollten infizierte ein reisen gehen die
behörden davon aus dass die opfer
schnell genug isoliert werden können
man kann nur hoffen dass das dann besser
als bei der schweinegrippe klappt
momentan besteht für uns hier in europa
also wohl keine gefahr
umso schlimmer ist allerdings die
epidemie in afrika
es bleibt zu hoffen dass die konferenz
der whu jetzt endlich zur eindämmung
führt regierung und behörden müssen
langsam den ernst der lage erkennen
hier klicken für das erste video zum
thema ebola als die solche ausbrach und
hier sind alle meldungen zu edler auf
klicks um de gesammelt was meint ihr
wird der ausbruch nicht ernst genug
genommen diskutiert es in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran